I mean I went to college in the 60s you
know that's what prompted me to to
pursue this line of research because I
saw that you know I went to an Ivy
League school and I went to Stanford
School of Medicine and you know I used
cannabis and I don't think it destroyed
my life
[Music]
Donald Abrams and I'm chief of
hematology oncology at San Francisco
General Hospital I'm a professor of
medicine at University of California San
Francisco in the clinic here at San
Francisco General Hospital we had a
volunteer Mary Rathbun who was our
volunteer of the year for two years in a
row she was an older woman and she used
to bring her kids as she called our
patients marijuana brownies this was at
a time when we didn't have any effective
therapies for hiv/aids and many people
were dying of the so called wasting
syndrome I was in Amsterdam of all
places at the International AIDS
Conference and glancing at CNN Headline
News and I saw that Mary was being
arrested in Sonoma for baking brownies
for our patients and when I arrived home
there was a letter directed to the
director of research in the AIDS program
at San Francisco general suggesting that
a clinical trial showing the benefits of
medical marijuana should come from
brownie Mary's institution as if she
were our Dean but you know I picked up
the gauntlet and decided well that's a
good idea
I had found out that the federal
government the only legal source of
cannabis for clinical trials being the
National Institute on Drug Abuse was not
interested or has a mandate from
Congress that they cannot supply
cannabis to study as a treatment because
as dr. leshner told me when I met with
him in 1996 he said we are the National
Institute on Drug Abuse not for drug
abuse so they have a congressional
mandate only to study substances of
abuse as substances of abuse and hence
could not give me marijuana to study to
see if it reversed the AIDS wasting
syndrome in California we were fortunate
at the end of the last century to have a
budget surplus and with that Senator
John vasconcelos established a center
for medicinal cannabis research at the
University of California through
appropriating three million dollars a
year for three years and that Center was
really developed to study cannabis as a
medicine for the indications that the
people of California had voted on in
1996 the federal government again
deciding that they're the only legal
source of cannabis sort of made
arrangements so that they would supply
the marijuana for these research
protocols even though they were looking
at marijuana's effectiveness as long as
they didn't have to pay to do the
studies so the state of California the
University of California Center for
medicinal cannabis research would fund
the research and NIDA would supply the
marijuana and so that was a big change
the the potency of the cannabis that we
get from NIDA the National Institute on
Drug Abuse is is low average is about
three point five maybe to four percent
and Street cannabis or cannabis that's
from the dispensaries I think is eight
to twelve to twenty percent so that
that's lower potency I asked NIDA can't
you make more potent cannabis you know
and they said well it turns out that
it's too sticky and it gums up their
machine because they are
automatically roll their marijuana for
research into cigarettes using pall mall
cigarette paper so so they did actually
for our vaporizer study they came up
with a six point eight percent THC which
they managed I don't know if they hand
rolled it or what but they did manage to
make a more potent strain a number of
the studies that we did were on painful
peripheral neuropathy because it's such
a hard syndrome to treat and there
aren't really effective therapies
opioids don't really work acupuncture is
plus - most people use anti-seizure
medicines and I think all the studies
from the University of California Center
for medicinal cannabis research have
shown that cannabis is very useful for
peripheral neuropathy we took patients
with chronic pain who were taking an
opioid either morphine extended-release
or oxycodone extended-release and we
expose them to vaporize cannabis for
five days and we looked at the impact on
the level of the opioid the morphine or
the oxycodone in their bloodstream and
the impact on their pain and we're in
the process of writing that one up but
it was very interesting and it supports
what we thought was going to happen in
that the blood levels of the opioid
either the morphine or the oxycodone
were actually decreased but pain relief
was increased with the cannabis so you
know that's a very interesting finding
other studies have been conducted in
patients with multiple sclerosis again
many patients with multiple sclerosis
report decrease in spasticity decrease
in pain increased mobility increased
mood improved mood when participating in
these studies
we've done a lot of research over the
past 20 years when we haven't been able
to do research with the actual cannabis
on how cannabinoids caused their effects
and what investigators found in the
1970s and 80s was that we have receptors
in our body cb1 and cb2 that complex
with these cannabinoids from the plants
now why would we and all other animal
species mind you have these cb1
receptors it's not because we're meant
to smoke marijuana what we find out is
that we have our own circulating
cannabinoid chemicals in our body that
don't come from the plant they're
generally produced on demand and they
complex with the receptor and they cause
a biological action so I drink green tea
for its health benefit and green tea has
a number of different chemicals that
produce these benefits
similarly cannabis the plant has a
number of active compounds called
cannabinoids and they belong to a family
of 21 carbon chemicals that all have
biologic activity we believe that
they're about 70 or 80 different
cannabinoids in marijuana the most
well-known and the most psychoactive
cannabinoid is Delta 9 THC and that has
been extracted from the plant and put in
a sesame oil capsule and has been
available as a drug during a banal now
for many years
however there are other cannabinoids in
the plant that have activity a study in
Israel looked at Delta eight THC and
found that it was equally effective as
an anti-nausea drug for children with
cancer getting chemotherapy I think most
of the interest now is on another
cannabinoid called cannabidiol otherwise
known as CBD this cannabinoid seems to
have really potent anti-inflammatory and
anti-pain activity without having a
psychological effect or without
producing a high it's a very exciting
field and many drug companies are
working to increase production of
endocannabinoids or decrease production
or block the cannabinoid receptor now
there was an example of a drug that was
approved to decrease appetite was
approved in Europe and it was a cb1
receptor blocker so that the receptor
could no longer bind with the body's own
endocannabinoids and what they found was
that by blocking that cb1 receptor that
patients lost weight but they got
depressed and they committed suicide and
that was a bad side effect so the drug
was never approved here in the US and
it's now been taken off the market in
Europe as an oncologist there's hardly a
cancer patient that I see for whom I
don't recommend cannabis because these
are patients especially those who are
undergoing chemotherapy who benefit from
anti nausea increased appetite we have
many many other anti-nausea drugs but
cannabis is the only drug that also
increases appetite and we know it
decreases pain again especially in
conjunction with opioids helps people
sleep better and it decreases depression
so those are five reasons that a cancer
patient might benefit from cannabis and
if I were not familiar with cannabis as
medicinal properties I would have to
prescribe five different medicines all
of which would have side effects
toxicity and cost if this were something
that we just discovered in the Amazon
you know everybody would be knocking
doors down to do clinical trials to
investigate its potential because it is
quite an amazing medicine I mean it it
is unfortunately all about politics and
not science and that's when it comes to
the health of the nation I think a
problem